FEMALE SPEAKER: Welcome
again to Authors at Google.
Welcome to the
parents who are here
for Take Your
Parents to Work Day.
We are excited to have
Brandon Sanderson here today.
He has written quite
a lot of books.
And has a lot in
the works, according
to Wikipedia, which is where
I got my info for this bio.
And it tells me he is best
known for his "Mistborn" series
and his work finishing
Robert Jordan's epic fantasy
series, "The Wheel
of Time," which
at least for me,
"The Wheel of Time"
is how I was introduced
to his works.
And I am glad that
I was because I
have loved the "Mistborn" books
as well as his new "Reckoners"
series, and can't wait
to read even more.
I think that's about all
I'm going to do for you,
short and sweet.
So please join me in
welcoming Brandon Sanderson.
[APPLAUSE]
BRANDON SANDERSON:
Thank you very much.
And thank you, Google.
This is actually my
fourth Google campus.
I'm trying to visit
them all, I guess.
It's like Pokemon.
What's that?
Yeah.
I get a badge for that.
So what we're going
to do today is
I'm actually going to talk
at you, just a little speech
for maybe 15, 20 minutes.
And then we will do a
short Q&A. And then, I'm
going to do a reading that takes
another 15, 20 minutes to wrap
off our whole hour here.
All right?
When I first went
on tour, I started
talking a lot about my
books at the speeches.
But then I started to
realize that everyone
who was at my
signings already had
the book I was talking about.
So I didn't really
need to do a hard sell.
So instead, I started
thinking about they give me
this platform.
I'm a university professor.
You give me a microphone
and a platform,
I'll start talking about stuff.
I started just talking a
little bit about whatever I
was thinking about at the time.
And it does usually
relate a little bit
to my writing in some way.
It's just whatever's
been inside my head.
People like to reach
in there and be like,
oh, this is what the
author is thinking about.
And my story, actually,
this time starts in Sharjah.
Does anyone know
where Sharjah is?
Oh, smart people in this room.
I had no idea where
Sharjah was when
they wrote me and said,
hey, would you like
to come to our book festival.
Turns out Sharjah is one of
the United Arab Emirates.
So you've heard of Dubai
and Abu Dhabi, most likely.
Sharjah is next door to them.
And you know, I get invitations
to book festivals quite a lot.
And I got this one
and said, free trip?
Sure.
I mean, I've never been
to the Middle East before.
And the United Arab
Emirates are right there
on the Arabian Peninsula,
right next to Saudi Arabia.
I thought, this
will be super cool.
I don't know if anyone
there reads my books.
Often, you get invitations
to these festivals
just because they're
looking and saying,
who is someone we
haven't had yet?
Him.
But it sounded like
it was a fun time.
And I said yes.
And indeed, over there--
if you get a chance,
the United Arab
Emirates is awesome.
I got to go out and
see the sand dunes.
Right?
These enormous-- we flew in
a helicopter for 45 minutes
over them.
They're just endless.
Right?
Over to the Arabian
border, and I
took lots of pictures of myself
on top of giant sand dunes
making Arrakis jokes.
You can tell I'm a nerd.
It's not Lawrence of Arabia.
It's like, walk
without rhythm, guys.
Sand worms will eat you.
But then it came time
to go to my signing.
And I was a little apprehensive
because you go to a signing,
you're never sure if anyone's
was going to show up.
And you go to a signing
in a foreign country,
you're extra uncertain
what it's going to be like,
what the expectations are.
And I walk into
the big hall where
they're having the signings.
And there's this
big line of people.
And they're wearing traditional
Emirati clothing, which
means for the women, they
wear the hi-jab, which
is the head scarf that leaves
the face open, the black one.
And they were wearing
the black dress.
And then the men are
wearing the thobe,
which is the white garments.
And then they have
their own headdress.
And it looks all very formal
and kind of intimidating.
And yet, they're all
holding huge stacks
of Brandon Sanderson
novels, these big stacks.
I mean, I feel so
bad for people.
They come to my signings.
My books kind of are big.
And so they're
lugging them along.
But I stopped and I look
at this big line of people,
and I think it's my people.
Right?
I've come home.
I've traveled across the world
to a completely different
culture.
And I found the
science fiction nerds.
And it was really
this wonderful moment
where I thought about the power
of storytelling and fiction
to connect people.
Here, I had somehow
made a connection
with people in a very
different culture from my own
writing these stories.
I sat in the line.
We got to talk about our
favorite Star Trek captains.
There was one woman there
who had just gotten back
from comic-con in Dubai.
And it was really cool.
She did a cosplay.
She dressed as the
character No-Face
from the Miyazaki film, which
is this character who is all
black with a white face mask.
She just put a face mask on.
She's like, I did it.
It was so easy!
It was an amazing, amazing
moment, just thinking about,
like I said.
That power of fiction.
I can read a book written
3,000 years ago by someone
on a different continent.
And I can feel the same
emotions they were feeling
when they wrote that story.
And that is absolutely amazing.
And so this led
me, as is natural,
to thinking about
King Sejong the Great.
Right?
That's where you
guys went, right?
King Sejong.
King Sejong is one my
favorite people in history.
He was king of
Korea in the 1400s.
And Sejong, when
he rose to power,
he had this really interesting
problem he wanted to solve.
And he did this in secret.
He gathered a bunch
of scholars together.
Very secret, very hush-hush.
It was like "Mission Impossible"
with Confucian scholar kings.
And he gets his
scholars together.
And he says, I want to
come up with a writing
system for my people.
Now, the thing is, back then
and still commonly in Asia,
but back then, you wrote Korean
using Chinese characters.
Does anyone here speak Chinese?
A few of you.
So I apologize for what
I'm about to do to Chinese.
And I don't know simplified.
I only know complex.
And I'm not very good at it.
But Chinese is this
really cool writing system
because what we Chinese is
what we call logographic.
At least, it's
mostly logographic.
That means that each Chinese
character represents an idea
rather than being
something phonetic
that you can sound out.
And this pen is not
working terribly well.
But it's OK.
And there's not supposed
to be one of those.
This one's better?
OK, I'll let you take that one.
Oh, that is way better.
If you want to
write, for instance,
"Korea," you have to
write it like this.
That's "Korea" in
Chinese characters,
written very poorly.
Now, the great thing about
this is, whatever your language
is, you can read this
in your language,
if you know the characters.
So if you show this
to someone in Japan,
they'll be like, oh,
that means "Korea."
If you show it to
someone in China,
you show it to someone in Korea,
show it to someone in Thailand,
someone in Mongolia, it
crosses cultural boundaries
really well because
the characters just
represent an idea.
But the big problem with Chinese
is that you can't sound it out,
which means that for
King Sejong's people, who
were mostly farmers,
not scholars,
memorizing thousands of these
things to be able to read
was very tough.
So his people were
completely illiterate.
And beyond that, can write
Chinese really well in this,
obviously.
But writing Korean is
difficult because Korean
has different conjugation
and structure than Chinese.
And so it's like, how do you
write the Korean conjugation.
You just can't.
You can't write
Korean possessives.
Korean, when you
write it out, whatever
your subject is, you put a
little marker on it to say,
this is our subject.
You write like [SPEAKS KOREAN].
You can't write that
with the Chinese.
You either have to
write in caveman speak.
Or you have to add in all these
characters that don't actually
mean what they say they mean.
And it gets really confusing.
And so King Sejong said,
I want to solve this.
We're going to
come up with a way
to write Korean that
works with the Chinese.
And they came up with
something really ingenious.
It's called Hangul.
And Hangul is this thing where
you create a phonetic version
of a Chinese character.
This is [SPEAKS  KOREAN]
Hangul, Korea.
And you put these together in
these syllable blocks, where
you construct something that
would work in the same writing
system with the Chinese, which
is really nifty because what
you can do is you can
still write in Chinese
and then add the Korean letters
to give the conjugation if you
want to.
Or you can just write
straight in Korean
and write it exactly
the same way.
Or you can drop in the
occasional cool Chinese
character to look awesome, which
is what people do these days.
If you want to be cool, you
write some words in Chinese.
You're like,
yeah,yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then the rest
is all in Korean
because Chinese just looks
beautiful on the page.
So King Sejong
came up with this.
It is amazing how
well this works.
In fact, Korea is one of
the most literate countries
in the world today, partially
because of how great
this writing system is.
Linguists just drool
over this writing system.
It is so nifty.
There's lots of really
cool things about it.
But he presents it to his court
after they come up with it.
And they hated it.
They absolutely hated it.
In fact, one of the people in
court wrote, "How could this
not to be a setback
to our civilization?
Spending too much thought
and effort on this
is a waste of time detrimental
to the timely pursuit
of scholarship."
Yeah.
So this cool system
that is brilliant
and since then has
been widely regarded
as one of the best
alphabets ever invented,
in fact, I think the
only major alphabet that
was designed by scholars rather
than arising accidentally.
So why did they hate it?
Any guesses?
AUDIENCE: It made
scholarship more accessible.
BRANDON SANDERSON: It made
That's exactly what it was.
At this time, if you know
anything about Confucian
society, taking the
tests in Chinese
to prove how great
you are at Chinese
is what got you a place
in the government, which
are the best jobs.
It was a mark of nobility.
And the idea that the
common people could read
was really a big
deal to the Koreans.
And it completely causes
a huge revolution.
There's these
stories, by the way,
King Sejong writing
Hangul on leaves
and spreading them through
the air to the people,
like people would see
it and be like oh,
and immediately recognize
that this is brilliant
and start being able to write
it because they found it
on the leaves.
But years later,
someone, one of the kings
tried to forbid this
because of this reason
to keep people from reading it.
By then, in just
a few generations,
it had become so
pervasive in the culture
that he couldn't stamp it out,
no matter how hard he tried.
This stuff is awesome.
And yet, people tried to keep
everyone else from reading.
And this is actually a theme.
This is a pretty big
theme through history.
The people who tried
to first translate
the Bible into English,
didn't go so well for them.
I don't know if you know that.
But they got burned
at the stake.
And the resistance
to literacy programs
in the 1800s in early 1900s
is shocking to us nowadays.
We're like, why would anyone
not want other people to read.
Well, it's a theme.
It's something for
some reason that people
who know something often
want to keep everyone
else from figuring it out.
And you might be saying,
OK, Brandon, we're
here at a book signing.
We work for Google.
We're good on this
literacy thing.
We promised to teach
people to read.
You're preaching to the choir.
Well, there's an
issue relating to this
that has really
started bothering me
over the last few years.
And I think we're doing
something very similar to what
these scholars are doing inside
of the science fiction/ fantasy
reading community.
Let me read you a quote from
a blogger named Bonnie Burton.
She says, "As a
geek girl, I have
been accused of wearing a Star
Wars shirt to get attention
from guys.
I've been told to move aside
and let real gamers play
the demos at conventions.
Lately, it seems elements
of the geek community
have become a lot less
a welcome wagon and more
a judgmental jedi council that
refuses to let newbies in,
especially if they
happen to be girls.
In a community once known
for celebrating outcasts
and underdogs, it
sometimes now seems
like you have to take some
sort of Voight-Kamff test
to prove your geekdom is legit."
And if you didn't
get that reference,
that is a "Blade
Runner" reference.
She is totally proving her
geekdom is legit with that one.
But there's this
sense that you have
to prove that you are
a true fan to become
part of our community.
Right?
And this is bigger than
the video game community.
It's this idea that with
how popular, for instance,
the comic book movies have
become, I found myself saying,
you guys are not
true "Iron Man" fans.
Or my big one was the turtles,
"Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles,"
right?
I read Eastman and
Laird original run
of "Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles"
when they all had red masks.
Right?
This is the way
it's supposed to be.
And when it's got
popular, I'm like,
you guys do not
know the Turtles.
You are not fans of my Turtles.
How dare you?
Right?
How many here--
because I've done it.
I'll raise my hand.
How many here have
made fun of "Twilight"?
Yeah.
Or "Eragon" or
"The Hunger Games,"
or whatever popular
fiction seems
to be bringing people into the
science fiction and fantasy
community at a time.
For some reason, those of
us entrenched inside of it
get really resistant.
I remember when I was at
science fiction conventions
in the late 90s, early
2000s, and people
referred to JK Rowling as
"that damn Scottish woman"
because all these people
inside the community
had had this club.
And suddenly, it was everywhere.
Now, it's hard to imagine that
now because JK Rowling went on
to win a Hugo Award.
She's been very accepted
by the community.
And yet, initially,
when something
takes off and gets
popular, the community
wants to push back against it.
And I found myself doing this.
Now, I want to take an aside.
I'm not saying we
can't criticize.
In fact, I think we should.
I have an English degree.
It's four years of learning
to criticize stuff, right?
It's important to
say, I don't like this
and this is why, to just
start that discourse,
to have a discussion.
But what I'm talking
about people doing
is less about the criticism
and more about the shaming.
Right?
It's the kid who gets
on the forums, excited
because he's read "Eragon."
And it's like he's
discovered something
that changed his life.
And he goes and he posts,
I love the fantasy books.
I just read "Eragon."
Can we talk about this?
And the responses, you can see
like 50 responses in a row of,
why don't you read
something real.
You idiot.
This is dumb.
That's just a copy of
"Star Wars," or whatever.
Just all the way down the list.
That's what I'm talking about.
And it's particularly
bad on the internet.
It's become worse and
worse over the last decade
because of just how we
are treating one another.
And that hurts me because
fiction is about connecting.
Right?
I spent several years in higher
education getting a master's
degree in creative writing.
And I had to fight every
day to convince them
that science fiction was legit.
Right?
I had professors who refused
to give me good grades
because I was writing fantasy
novels and turning them in.
And so to have been
fighting all that and then
to see our community
doing it to the people who
are trying to get in and be
part of it really bothers me.
So this is my plea
and my request.
Can we be a little less acerbic?
Can we be a little less
hateful, a little less critical?
Can we talk about
what we like and don't
like without dragging
the people who like what
we don't into the discussion.
Right?
Can we keep it about
the fiction and less
about the people who love it.
And next time you run into
something that you're like,
I just don't like
this, maybe instead of
your first instinct being
to go online and say,
everyone who likes this
is stupid, maybe give it
another read, maybe
read through something
you wouldn't have before.
And you don't have to like it.
But read through it with
the intent of figuring out
why other people love it.
And if you can figure that
out, if you can do that,
then the fiction is still
fulfilling its purpose.
It's doing what I did
when I went to Sharjah
and I was able to
connect with people.
You can connect
with people who are
different than yourselves, who
like things different than you
do.
And if you can figure out
why they love something,
I think you'll understand
them a little bit better.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
So let's go ahead and
do a short Q&A. Anything
you guys are interested
in asking me, go ahead.
And I'll just repeat
the questions.
That will be easier for the
camera and things like that.
So whatever you want to
know, I'll answer them.
And then we'll do the reading.
Any questions?
Oh, no questions.
OK, right here.
AUDIENCE: You're known to
be a very prolific writer.
What do you attribute
your productivity to?
BRANDON SANDERSON: So I'm known
to be a very prolific writer.
To what do I attribute
my productivity?
I can liken this one to Google.
I remember the first
time I visited Google.
It was the Seattle campus.
And I got there.
And they had valet
parking for the engineers.
And I'm like, valet
What's going on?
They're like, well, you
know, it might take them
a little too long
to find a space
because it's of tight here.
We want them to just get
in and start working.
And then I go in and they have
this full-service cafeteria
that's serving
this amazing food.
And I'm like, this is all free?
And they're like, yeah, yeah.
And then there's massage tables.
There's candy.
And I realized all
they wanted to do
was keep you there
working and make
you forget what time it was.
So it's like midnight.
And you're like, oh, I've just
been enjoying myself so much.
Or one of the people
joked that it's
like they start dinner
at a certain time
so if you get done
working, you're like,
oh, if I just wait another
hour or two, dinner's here.
Right?
And it's all kind of designed
around this idea of keeping
you happy and working.
That's my life, right?
I love my job.
And I work from home for
most of the time, which
means that I actually have
plenty of time with my family
because I work from
about noon until 5:00.
And I get done, I play
with my kids, my family,
from about 5:30 to
about 8:30, 9:00.
And then I go back to work.
And I work from 9:00 or
10:00 until 3:00 or 4:00.
And I enjoy my job.
And I don't have a commute.
Right?
I'm just there.
And it's like, I could
go do something else,
or I could do what I love.
And what I love usually wins.
I'm not that fast a writer.
But what I am is I'm
a consistent writer.
And I'm very passionate
about what I do.
And so I produce around
2,000 words a day, basically
every day.
And that just adds up.
So yep.
All right, other questions?
Right there.
AUDIENCE: How much
of your writing
do you plot out in advance
and how much unfolds?
BRANDON SANDERSON:
Oh, good question.
How much do I plot out in
advance and how much unfolds?
So most writers fall
somewhere on a spectrum
between what we call discovery
writers and outline writers.
George R. Martin has
great terms for these.
He calls them gardeners
and architects.
And I am much more an architect.
I would say about 70/30
on the architect side.
So what I do is I
build an outline.
I actually build it in reverse.
I start with what I
want to have happen.
And then I work backward.
And it's not like
Heading A, Subheading
B. It's not like that.
What I do is I think, all right,
I've got these two characters.
What's their
relationship going to be?
How are they going to interact?
All right, what's the end goal?
What do I want the moment
between them at the end to be?
It can be they don't
like each other.
It can be they like
each other, whatever.
I will then brainstorm
steps along the way
as a list of bullet points.
And I'll do that for every
subplot-- my mystery, how
does the magic work, a training,
a character becoming better
at something, any sort of
we need to figure this out.
And the main one
is usually whatever
the big plot of the book
is, but all the subplots.
And so I have all of these
goals and bullet points.
And that becomes my outline.
When I work forward, I'm
grabbing these bullet points
and weaving them in
as I go so that I
make sure I'm getting all
the proper foreshadowing
for the different subplots.
I do a lot of planning in my
worldbuilding ahead of time,
a ton of that.
Worldbuilding is
very important to me.
One of the things I've
tried to bring to fantasy
is I would like to have a
little bit of a science fiction
rigor for fantasy worlds,
which is not something
that, as a reader,
I've found a lot of.
And so it felt like
a hole in the genre
that I wanted to fill.
My characters, I do not
do a lot of planning.
I figure out who they are.
But usually, I do that
by writing some scenes
through their viewpoint and
try to explore who they are.
And then I'm like,
all right, I got
a feel for who this person is.
Let's build a plot for them.
But it's very vague
and very loose.
And that trumps all
the other stuff.
If I'm writing this character
along and who they're becoming
would not fulfill the plot
that is planned for them,
then I have to go
rebuild my outline,
or I have to tear the character
out and put a new character
in that place.
So I've done both,
depending on the situation.
And so it's this organic thing.
And I do that very
intentionally because outline
writers tend to have a
problem that their endings are
explosive but their
characters are weak.
And discovery writers
tend to have weak endings
and great characters.
And if you take
that as a guide, you
can usually figure out
who is who in writing.
Right?
You usually can.
You can figure out if they're
more an outline writer or more
a discovery writer.
And where books really
start to take off, I feel,
is where you can
hybridize the two,
and you can use the discovery
writing for the characters
and the outlining for the plot.
And when you can get those
two working really well,
that's where I
think books really
start to come together for me.
So there you are.
Let's go right here.
AUDIENCE: So sort of
a related question,
but on the [INAUDIBLE] level.
You have this universe
connecting a lot of your books.
BRANDON SANDERSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: To what
extent do you have
that built out in your head?
BRANDON SANDERSON: Excellent.
So I have something
called the Cosmere.
If you're unfamiliar,
my epic fantasies
are all connected in
very subtle, minor ways.
They are cameos from different
characters in each one.
So any of my books that
don't mention Earth
tend to be in the Cosmere.
That's rule of thumb,
what is and what isn't.
And I'm weaving a few
characters with a hidden epic
behind the scenes that
I'll eventually get to.
Right now, it's all
just Easter eggs.
But because I'm
planning all this,
I have to have a really solid
outline for the entire Cosmere.
When I originally plotted it,
it was between 32 and 36 books,
depending on which books got
split and things like that.
And yes, I have a pretty
solid outline for all of that.
The fortunate aspect of
that is remember that it's
all Easter eggs for right now.
So you can read the
series out of order.
It doesn't matter.
You're not missing anything.
You just have to watch for
some of these characters that
are popping in and out.
And eventually, you'll find more
and more of what they're doing.
That does require
a lot of plotting.
And it's something I did because
some of my favorite writers
connected some of their
worlds late in life.
And I thought it was brilliant.
But it also was obvious
they didn't do it
from the beginning.
Right?
Isaac Asimov wove
together the robots
in "Foundation" in
a really clever way.
But it wasn't there
from the get go.
He just figured it
out later on, which
is what you have to do when
you start writing and the 30s
and you weave them together in
the 70s or something like that.
But that inspired me.
I'm like, he's done that.
Stephen King did the
thing where he kind of
tied them all together with the
Dark Tower and stuff like this.
Can I do something from
the get go that plans this?
And so from "Elantris," my first
book, which was sold in 2003,
I have all of these kinds of
thing seeded with the idea
being that there is
an overarching plot
for the whole thing.
So it is coming.
But there's a lot of
that's a ways off.
The "Mistborn" books are
forming a core for that, which--
Yeah, I should actually talk
about my book, shouldn't I?
When I originally pitched
"Mistborn" to my editor,
I said, I want to do something
I haven't seen in fantasy.
It's kind of one of
my guiding principles.
Have I seen it done in fantasy?
Let's see if we can do it.
I want to do a
fantasy world that
evolved into a modern-day
world that eventually evolved
into a science fiction world.
And the magic becomes
the means by which
space travel is possible.
Right?
And so I wrote this
epic fantasy trilogy.
And then I jumped
forward and I'm
kind of doing 1910s era to show
how the fantasy books became
the foundation of mythology
and history for a modern take.
And then I'm going
contemporary-ish next.
I'm really probably
going go in 1980s, kind
of Tom-Clancy-esque spy epics.
But you guys will like that one.
The main character
in that, she's
a programmer in a
very early programming
language on Scadriel.
So imagine a programmer who
gets recruited by the CIA
to go be a field agent.
It'll make sense when I do it.
But we will eventually evolve
that into a science fiction
space epic.
So that's where I'm
going with those.
And I should have
mentioned when I did this,
this was actually the
inspiration for "Elantris."
This idea of the Chinese
characters and Korean,
because I speak Korean.
I've been learning this.
It was really cool.
And that's why my very first
published book, "Elantris,"
has this magic system based
around these cool characters
and the language
surrounding them.
Let's go do like one
more question right here.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How do you feel
about movie adaptations
of your books?
Would you be open to that?
BRANDON SANDERSON:
Would I be open to doing
movie adaptations of my books?
I would love to see
movie adaptations done.
I am child of the 70s.
or of the 80s, really.
And I was born in '75.
I grew up with "Star Wars."
I grew up with all
this stuff, right?
Science fiction
cinematic history
is a big part of what
made me into a writer.
And so yes.
Now, I understand that
sometimes they screw it up.
And I say "they"
as a nebulous they.
Usually, when films
go wrong, it's
not because someone is
trying to make a bad film.
It just doesn't come together.
But I would rather roll
the dice on a good film
and risk having a bad film.
That's something that I
would very much like to do.
So I have sold the rights
to several of my series.
"Mistborn" is owned
by one company.
"The Reckoners" is owned by Fox
with Shawn Levy's production
company.
He's the one who did "The
Night at the Museum" films,
and a film called "Real Steel,"
which I highly recommend.
If you haven't seen it's,
it's great film-- "Wolverine"
with fighting robots.
And then "The Emperor's Soul"
is owned by DMG Entertainment.
So I've sold a lot of these.
And I'm working with them.
They've all been very
easy to work with.
But nothing has gotten
a green light yet.
So until something
gets a green light,
it means it's just
in production.
And it could be there
for the next 20 years.
So don't hold your breath.
One in 30 of these
is the statistic
I keep hearing that get made.
But I'm very hopeful.
All right, I'm going to go
ahead and stop now and go
ahead and go into the reading.
Now, this reading
is actually going
to be from the third
"Stormlight" book.
But I am reading a
flashback sequence
for a character
named Dalinar, which
means if you haven't read
the other "Stormlight" books,
it's not a spoiler
because it takes place
30 years before the
first book begins.
It may change your
perception of this character
when we get to him.
But so I'm going
to do this reading.
It's about 20 minutes long.
This doesn't matter to you.
But for parents who
might be watching,
this is a little bit
on the violent side.
I mean, it's Dalinar at war.
So yeah, yeah.
Well, we're recording this.
They're going to put it up.
So I wanted to put that
little warning there.
That's why I said, for parents
who might be watching this.
Yeah, I'm talking to the
video camera for that one,
not to you guys.
I understand.
I understand you
can handle PG-13.
All right
"Rockbuds crunched like
skulls beneath Dalinar's boots
as he charged across
the burning field.
His elites tromped behind him,
a hand-picked force of soldiers
both light-eyed and dark.
They weren't an honor guard.
Dalinar didn't need guards.
These were simply the men
he considered competent
enough not to embarrass him.
"Around him, rockbuds smoldered.
Moss, dried from the
summer heat and long days
between storms
this time of year,
flared up in waves,
setting the rockbud shells
themselves aflame.
Dalinar charged the smoke,
trusting in his padded armor
and thick boots to protect him.
Flamespren, like tiny
people made of fire,
danced from one patch
of flame to the next.
"The enemy, pressed by
his armies from the North,
had pulled back into
the town just ahead.
Dalinar had held himself
back with difficulty
from entering that
initial clash.
He'd known the real fighting
would take place here
in the town.
He hadn't expected the enemy
to, in a desperate move, fire
this plain, burning
their own crops
to block the southern approach.
"Well, no matter.
The fires could go to damnation
for all Dalinar cared.
He led his men in a charge.
And though some were overwhelmed
by the smoke or heat,
most stayed with him.
They'd crash into the
enemy from the South,
pressing them between his
men here and the main army.
Hammer and anvil, the
best kind of tactic,
the type that didn't allow his
enemies to get away from him.
"As Dalinar burst
from the smoky air,
he found a few lines of
spearmen hastily making ranks
on the southern
edge of the town.
There were remnants of a wall.
But that had been
torn down years ago.
Dalinar had forgotten
the town's name.
But the location was ideal.
A large ridge to the East made
a natural break from the storms
and had allowed this place to
sprawl almost like a real city.
"Dalinar screamed at
the enemy soldiers,
beating a sword-- just a regular
longsword-- against his shield.
He wore a sturdy
breastplate and helm along
with iron-lined boots.
The spearmen ahead
of him wavered
as his elites roared
from the smoke and flame,
shouting a
bloodthirsty cacaphony.
A few of the spearmen
dropped weapons and ran.
Fearspren, like
globs of violet goo,
wriggled up from the ground en
masse around the enemy rank.
"Dalinar grinned.
He didn't need
Shards to intimidate.
He hit the spearman
like a boulder,
rolling through a grove of
saplings, swinging his sword
and sending limbs into the air.
A good fight was about momentum.
Don't stop.
Don't think.
Drive forward and
convince your enemies
that they were as
good as dead already.
That way, they'd fight
you less as you sent them
to their pyres.
As he waded among
them, the spearmen
thrust weapons
frantically toward him,
less trying to killed
Dalinar and more
trying to push away this madman.
Their ranks collapsed.
And many of them turned their
sides to Dalinar's elites.
"Dalinar laughed, slamming aside
a pair of spears with a shield,
then disemboweling one man
with a sword deep in the gut.
He jumped and left the man to
drop his spear, and in a panic,
trying to grab at his entrails.
The man's allies backed
away at the horrific sight.
So Dalinar came in swinging,
catching the two off balance,
killing them with the sword
that bore their friend's blood.
"Dalinar's elites decimated
the now broken line.
Dalinar himself pushed forward,
keeping momentum, shearing
through the ranks until
he reached the back,
breathing deeply and wiping
ashen sweat from his face.
A young spearman
fell before him,
crying, screaming
for his mother as he
crawled across the stony
ground, trailing blood.
Fearspren mixed with
Painspren all around.
"Dalinar shook his head,
picking up a fallen spear
and striding past the
youth, slamming it down
in the boy's back.
Men often cried for their
parents as they died.
Didn't matter how old they were.
He'd seen gray beards do it,
same as kids like this one.
'He's not much younger than
I am,' Dalinar thought.
'Maybe 17.' But then Dalinar
had never felt young,
regardless of his age.
His elites filled in
behind him, having
carved the enemy line in two.
Dalinar danced, shaking
off his bloody blade,
feeling alert, excited,
but not yet alive.
Where was it?
'Come on,' he thought.
"A larger group of
soldiers hiked down
the street toward him, led by
some officers in white and red.
Dalinar could see from
the way they pulled up,
alarmed, that they hadn't
expected their spearmen
to fall so quickly.
Dalinar charged.
His elites knew to watch.
So he was followed by
a force of 50 or 60.
The rest had to finish off
the unfortunate spearmen.
Well, 50 would do.
The crowded confines
of the town would mean
Dalinar shouldn't need more.
As he neared this newer force,
he focused his attention
on the one man riding a horse.
The fellow wore
plate armor obviously
meant to recreate Shardplate,
though it was only
of common steel.
It lacked the beauty,
the power, of true Plate.
He still looked like he was the
most important person around.
Hopefully, that would
mean he was the best.
"The man's honor guard
rushed to engage.
And Dalinar felt something
stir inside of him
like a thirst, a physical need.
Challenge, he needed
a challenge, storm it!
He let his elites
handle the honor guard.
He made his way
toward the Brightlord.
The man wasn't old enough
to be the highprince.
Some other important lighteyes?
Or didn't Dalinar remember
something about a son
during Gavilar's endless
planning meetings?
Well, this man certainly looked
grand on that white mare,
watching the battle
behind a helmed face.
"The foe turned toward
Dalinar and raised his sword
to his helm in a sign
of a challenge accepted.
Idiot.
Dalinar raised his
shield arm and pointed,
counting on at least
one of his strikers
to have lived and
stayed with him.
Indeed, Jenin
stepped up, unhooked
the short bow from his back.
And as the Brightlord
shouted in surprise,
shot the horse in the chest.
"'Hate shooting
horses,' Jenin grumbled,
as the beast reared in pain.
"like throwing 1,000 broams into
the storming ocean, Brightlord.
"'I'll buy you two
when we finish this,"
Dalinar said as the Brightlord
tumbled backward off his horse.
"Dalinar dodged around flashing
hooves and snorts of pain,
seeking out the fallen man.
He was pleased to
find the enemy rising.
Dalinar came in swinging.
The Brightlord managed
to get his sword up.
And Dalinar battered it away
and then dropped his own shield
completely, and came in with
a two-handed power swing,
intending to knock the
lighteyed soldier back down.
Fortunately, the man was good
enough to recover his stance
and intercept the
blow with his shield.
They probably heard
the subsequent crack
all the way in Kholinar.
indeed, it vibrated
up Dalinar's arms.
"Momentum, life
was about momentum.
Pick a direction and don't
let anything, man or storm,
turn you aside.
Dalinar battered
at the Brightlord,
driving him backward until
surprisingly, the men managed
to pull a feint,
and getting close,
to ram Dalinar with his shield.
Dalinar ducked the sword
swing that followed.
But the backhand hit him
solidly on the side of the head,
sending him stumbling,
his helm twisted,
metal bent by the blow biting
into his scalp, drawing blood.
He saw double.
His vision swimming.
"He roared at the lord, as
the lord smartly came in
for the kill.
Dalinar swept his blade up in
a lurching, full-shoulder blow,
slapping the lord's
weapon out of his hands
and tossing both swords away.
The man in turn punched Dalinar
in the face with his gauntlet.
And Dalinar's nose crunched.
Dalinar fell to his
knees, vision blurry.
His foe was breathing deeply,
cursing between breaths,
winded by the short,
frantic contest.
The Brightlord fished
at his belt for a knife.
"An emotion stirred
instead of Dalinar, a fire
that filled the pit within.
It washed through him and
awakened him, bringing clarity.
The sounds of his elites
fighting the Brightlord's honor
guard faded, metal on metal
becoming distant clinks, grunts
becoming like a humming.
Dalinar grinned.
Then that grin became
a toothy smile.
His vision returned
as the Brightlord, who
had just retrieved his
knife, looked up and started,
stumbling back.
He seemed horrified.
"Dalinar roared, spitting
blood and throwing himself
at the enemy.
The swing that came
for him seem pitiful.
And Dalinar ducked it, pushing
his shoulder against his foe
and shoving him backward.
Something thrummed
inside of Dalinar,
the pulse of the battle, the
rhythm of killing and dying,
the Thrill.
He knocked his opponent
off balance, then reached
for his sword.
"Dym, however, hollered his
name and tossed him a pole axe,
with a hook on one side and
broad, thin axe on the other.
Dalinar seized it
from the air and spun,
ducking the lord's swing.
At the same time,
he hooked the man
around the ankle with
the axe-head and yanked.
The Brightlord fell
in a clatter of steel.
"Unfortunately, before
Dalinar could attack further,
the honor guard became a bother.
Two had managed to extricate
themselves from Dalinar's men.
And they came to the
defense of their lord.
Dalinar caught their sword
strikes on his polearm
and twisted about,
backing away and bringing
the axe-head slamming
into one man's side.
Dalinar ripped it
free and spun again,
this time smashing the weapon
against the rising lord's head
and sending him to his knees.
"Then he came back
and barely managed
to catch the other guard's sword
on the haft of his polearm.
Dalinar pushed upward, holding
the polearm in two hands,
sweeping the guard's blade
into the air over his head
and stepping forward
until he was face-to-face
with the fellow.
He could feel the man's
breath on his face.
"Dalinar spit blood
from a shattered nose
into the guard's eyes, then
kicked him in the stomach.
He turned toward the lord,
who had scrambled again
to his feet, and was
now trying to flee.
Dalinar growled,
full of the Thrill,
and swung his
polearm by one hand,
hooking the spike
in the lord's side
and yanking, dropping
him a third time.
The lord rolled.
And this time, he was greeted
by the sight of Dalinar slamming
his polearm down by
two hands, driving
the spike right through the
breastplate and into the chest.
It made a satisfying crunch.
And Dalinar pulled
it out, bloodied.
"The blow seemed
a signal of sorts.
And the honor guard
and other soldiers
finally broke before his elites.
Dalinar grinned
as he watched them
go, Gloryspren
popping up around him
like glowing, golden spheres.
His men took out
their short bows
and managed to drop a good
dozen of the fleeing enemy
in the backs.
Damnation, it felt good to best
to force larger than his own.
"The Thrill dwindled.
He could never seem to hold
onto it as long as he wanted.
Nearby, the man he'd
felled groaned softly.
Dalinar stepped over, curious,
kicking at the armored chest.
"Why, the man said
from within his helm.
'Why us?'
"'Don't know,' Dalinar said,
tossing the polearm back
to Dym.
"'You-- you don't know?'
"'My brother chooses.
I just go where he points me.
"He gestured toward
the dying man.
And Dym rammed his sword in
the hole in the breastplate,
finishing the job.
The fellow had fought
reasonably well.
No need to extend his suffering.
"Another soldier approached,
handing Dalinar his sword.
It had a chip the size of
a thumb right in the blade.
Looked like it
had bent, as well.
"'You're supposed to stick
it in the squishy parts,
Brightlord,' Dym said, 'not
pound it against the hard
parts.'
"'I'll keep that in
mind,' Dalinar said,
tossing the sword aside,
as one of his men selected
a replacement from among the
fallen of high enough rank
to have one.
"'You all right, Brightlord?'
"'Never been better,'
Dalinar said,
then sucked the blood up
through his broken nose.
Hurt like damnation itself.
"His men formed around him.
And Dalinar led the way
further down the street.
Before too long,
he could make out
the bulk of the enemy still
fighting ahead, harried
by his main army.
He halted his elites,
contemplating.
"'Orders, sir?' Thakka,
Captain of the Elites, asked.
"'Raid those buildings,'
Dalinar said,
pointing at a line of homes.
'Let's see how well they fight
while they see us rounding up
their families.'
"Thakka nodded,
shouting the orders.
Dalinar reached for some water.
He'd need to meet
up with Sadeas,
and-- something slammed
into Dalinar's shoulder.
He got only a brief
sight of it, a black blur
that hit with the force
of a roundhouse kick.
It threw him down.
And pain flared
up from his side.
"'An arrow?' he said, blinking
as he found himself lying
on the ground.
A storming arrow sprouted
from his right shoulder, one
with a long, thick shaft.
It had gone right
through the plate.
"'My Lord,' Thakka
said, kneeling,
shielding Dalinar with his body.
Kelek!
Brightlord, are you--
"'Who in damnation shot
that?' Dalinar demanded.
"'Up there,' Dym said,
pointing at a ridge above town.
"'That's got to be over
300 yards,' Dalinar said,
shoving Thakka
aside and standing.
'That can't possibly--
"He was watching.
So he was able to jump out
of the way of the next arrow,
which dropped a mere foot from
him, slamming against the stone
ground.
Dalinar stared at it,
then started shouting.
"'Horses!
Where are the storming horses?'
"Had the fires delayed them?
No, fortunately.
A small group of soldiers had
guided them more carefully
across the fields, but
had caught up by now.
They stood with the
rear guard of the elites
and came trotting forward as
Dalinar's order was passed,
bringing all 11 horses.
Dalinar had to
dodge another arrow
as he seized the reins of
Fullnight, his black gelding,
and heaved himself
into the saddle.
He galloped back the
way he'd came in,
trailed by 10 of his best men.
There had to be a
way up that slope.
There, a rocky set
of switchbacks,
shallow enough that he didn't
mind running Fullnight up them.
Dalinar was more worried that
by the time he reached the top,
his quarry would have escaped.
"He eventually burst onto
the top of the ridge.
And an arrow slammed
into his left shoulder,
going straight through
the breastplate
and nearly throwing
him from the saddle.
Damnation.
He hung on somehow, clenching
the reins in one hand
and leaning low, watching
ahead as the archer,
still a distant figure,
stood upon a rocky knob
and launched another
arrow, and another.
Storms, the fellow was quick.
"Dalinar jerked Fullnight
to one side, then the other,
feeling the thrumming
sense of the Thrill return.
It pushed back the pain as
hooves made a clatter on stone.
And another arrow zipped past
his face, dangerously close.
Ahead, the archer finally
seemed to grow alarmed and lept
from his perch to flee.
Dalinar are charged
Fullnight right over that lip
a moment later, jumping the
horse after the fleeing archer,
who turned out to be a
man in his 20s wearing
rugged clothing.
Dalinar had the option to run
him down, but instead, galloped
Fullnight right past and
kicked the archer in the back,
sending him sprawling.
Dalinar pulled up his
horse, then turned it about
to pass by the groaning
archer, who lay in a heap
amid spilled black arrows.
"Dalinar's elites caught
up as he climbed roughly
from the saddle, an arrow
sprouting from each shoulder.
He seized the archer, who had
finally struggled to his feet
and was moving, dazed,
for his belt knife.
Dalinar turned the fellow
about, noting the blue tattoo
on his cheek.
The archer gasped,
staring at Dalinar,
who was covered in soot from the
fires, his face a mask of blood
from the broken nose and cut
scalp, and stuck with not one,
but two arrows.
"'You waited until my helm
was off,' Dalinar demanded.
"You are an assassin.
You were sent here
specifically to watch for me.'
"The man winced as
Dalinar gripped him hard,
but then nodded.
"'Amazing, Dalinar said,
letting go of the fellow.
'Show me that shot again.
How far is that, Thakka?
I'm right, aren't I?
Over 300 yards?
"'Almost four,' Thakka said,
'ut with a height advantage.'
"'Still, Dalinar said, stepping
up to the lip of the ridge.
He looked back at
the befuddled archer.
"'Well, go grab your bow.'
"'My bow,' the archer said.
"'Are you deaf, man?
Go get it!'
"The man regarded the 10
armed elites on horseback,
grim-faced and dangerous,
before wisely deciding to obey.
He picked up his bow
and a few arrows,
then stepped hesitantly
over to Dalinar,
giving one glance to
the similar shafts that
were still sprouting from him.
"'Went right through my storming
armor,' Dalinar muttered,
shading his eyes.
To his right, the
armies clashed.
And the main body of elites
had come up to press the flank.
The rear guard and
found some civilians
and was shoving them
out onto the street.
"'Pick a corpse,' Dalinar said,
pointing to a nearby square
where a skirmish had happened.
'Stick an arrow in one
of those, if you can.'
"The archer licked his lips,
still seeming confused.
Finally, he took a spyglass of
his belt and studied the area.
"'That one in blue,'
he finally said,
'near the overturned cart.'
"Dalinar squinted, then nodded.
Nearby, Thakka had
climbed off his horse
and had slid out his
sword, resting it
on his shoulder in a
not-so-subtle warning.
The archer contemplated
this, then drew his bow,
and launched a single
black-fletched arrow.
It soared true, sinking
into the chosen corpse.
"'Stormfather,' Dalinar
said, lowering his hand.
"Thakka, before today, I'd have
bet you half the princedom that
such a shot wasn't possible.'
"He turned to the archer.
"'What's your name, assassin?'
"The man raised his
chin, but didn't reply.
"'Well, either way,
welcome to my elites.
Somebody get this
fellow a horse.
"'What?
the archer said. 'I
tried to kill you.'
"'Yes, from a distance, which
shows remarkably good judgment.
I have use for someone
of your skills.'
"'We're enemies.'
"Dalinar nodded
toward the town below,
where the beleaguered enemy
army was, at long last,
surrendering.
"'Not any more.
Looks like we're
all allies now.'"
And there it is.
That's the end, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
So for those wondering,
it's out next November.
And for those who haven't read
those books or any of my books,
I'm not sure if that's the
best introduction to Dalinar
you can get.
Most of them are not
quite that Dalinar running
around killing people ish ness.
That's a word.
String that together.
Either way, I really
appreciate you guys
having me in to Google.
I get to check this
one off my list.
And hopefully, I'll get to
many more in the future.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]